and so I'm thinking about a topic for
tonight this in keeping with this idea
of impact and innovation while also
simultaneously trying to be somewhat
entertaining and interesting and
capturing what's unique about Carnegie
Mellon we thought that a panel session
on art and technology was ideal for many
reasons first and foremost is that these
are two areas where Carnegie Mellon has
incredibly deep strengths in terms of
you know being an incredible School of
Fine Arts and of course incredible
schools of technology and computer
science double et cetera we have
graduates around the world who are
renowned artists actors musicians you've
seen them in the theater you've seen
them in the movies and we have graduates
are renowned engineers and computer
scientists many of you here so it's a
perfect theme but equally what's
important to me about this subject is
that if you go back through humanity
that you know through the history you
know millions of years ago and you look
at sort of how human beings evolved it
seems that there are two things that the
human beings did that make us uniquely
human one of them is we develop
technology unlike really any other
animal species we developed technologies
that you know help us eat help us hunt
and that makes a lot of sense and then
we do this other thing we make art which
seems to have less evolutionary value
yet it turns out we do it anyway and we
do it with great passion and in fact we
build as I tell my daughters who are
artists and my wife I say you know not
only did we we do this art but we build
these museums and people spend millions
and millions of dollars to an art so
there must be something very very
important to human beings about art and
again that was thinking about this panel
I thought it would be really interesting
to to kind of look at that so Carnegie
Mellon's a unique institution because it
has great strengths in both of these
areas and as I think as you'll see with
tonight's panel the crossover between
art and technology at Carnegie Mellon is
stronger than ever and the boundary
between the two is blurrier than ever so
I want to show you a little video and
though tonight's panel isn't
specifically about computer-based art it
is interesting to trace back to the
beginning of when it became possible to
both interact within use computers to
display images in this case in the video
that you're watching the starting point
is the work of it incredibly well known
Carnegie Mellon really Carnegie Tech
graduate Ivan Sutherland his doctoral
thesis which was being shown here
sketchpad was done in the early 1960s
and it's very very much the start of the
whole field of visual and interactive
computing and by extension
technology-based art if you've never
seen sketch pad I encourage you to go
out on the web and search for it and
you'll see some pretty amazing things
that even to today and if you ask some
of the people in the audience who really
are experts in computer graphics they'll
tell you it's still amazingly innovative
stuff we don't have time to talk about
sketch pad really but you can see it's
used to draw on design objects and
remember this is 40 years ago when just
doing all this was hard but what's
impressive beyond the thesis is that
there's a quote from Ivan Allen Allen k
was interviewing him Allen asked him you
know so Ivan how is it that you
developed the first interactive graphic
system the first non procedural
programming language in the first
object-oriented software system and
Ivan's response was quote I didn't know
it was hard and I think that that could
I think as much as any other quote that
captures the spirit of Carnegie Mellon
and its graduates and if sketch pad is
the start of the computer-based tools
for artists then I think it's fair to
say that product sections adobe
photoshop adobe illustrator are among
the current pinnacles of sex tools and
if you don't already know and i'm sure
many of you do it's not a surprise that
Chuck gash be one of Dobies co-founders
is a computer science graduate from
Carnegie Mellon equally unsurprising is
both Ivan and Jacques are on the fellow
wall out here at the Museum they're
probably several others but those those
do I happen to know as Ray said Sarah
and I are very very interested in art
and technology it kind of runs in our
blood Sarah my wife is in 30 years is a
wonderful wonderful artist our daughter
is an actress our other daughter who
unfortunately feeling well tonight is an
artist as well and so art and technology
really really run in our blood and
that's part of our reason for being so
passionate
about Carnegie Mellon so with that by
way of background let's move on to the
panel discussion the format's I'm going
to pose some questions and then if
there's time if they think there will be
we'll take some questions from the
audience so please be thinking of some
things you want to go ask and so it's
with great pleasure that I'd like to
introduce tonight's panelists all of
whom are distinguished practitioners at
the intersection of art and technology
each as you'll see in a very very unique
way so I'm going to go read their BIOS
if all goes well you'll see some of
their works for each of them as I'm
talking so the first person I'd like to
introduce is Ralph Guggenheim a Ralph is
a 1974 graduate from the College of
Humanities and Social Sciences in a 1970
graduate of the melon college of science
which used to be known as the melon
institute of science ralph is an amazing
innovator in the field of computer
animation and his work has had a major
impact on the film industry currently he
is the chief executive officer of
alligator planet a SAN francisco-based
production company where he is working
on a pilot and i know if that's what's
shown here but for a fox TV animated
series ralph was also co-founder of
Pixar Animation Studios which ray
mentioned earlier which produce six
landmark films his toy story which I'm
sure you've all seen and the world's
first feature-length computer animated
film so this is a summer rouse work
yeah so we'll wait for a little video
here but you can see it's amazing stuff
so the next person I'd like to introduce
and ray mentioned EA earlier is Richard
hilliman Richard is the chief creative
director of electrical electronic arts
which has partnered with Carnegie Mellon
on revolutionary programming tools
including randy pausch as alice 30
Richard is a video game producer best
known for his work creating the original
Madden football game for gaming consoles
for electronic arts today Madden is the
best-selling title in history in North
America and Richard Idzik was a key in
doing that isn't a key in building the
worldwide EA sports brands again if any
of you play video games you guys know EA
richard has been executive producer or
producer for other successfully a sports
titles in the 1990s including NHL hockey
pga tour golf and tiger woods golf tiger
probably needed some help today but
anyway since 2000 richard has been
spending his time teaching master
production classes inside of EA and
doing an amazing job contributing to
university programs outside of EA
okay our next panelist is a Carnegie
Mellon professor Golan Levin who's an
artist in an engineer interested in
exploring new modes of reactive
expression through performances digital
artifacts virtual environments Golan
applies creative twists to digital
technologies that highlight our
relationship with machines make visible
our ways of interacting with each other
and explore the intersection of
nonverbal communication and
interactivity Golan has exhibited
performed widely in Europe America and
Asia and does amazing stuff as you'll
see as an educator Golan's pedagogy is
concerned with reclaiming computation as
a medium of personal expression I bet
you've never heard that before his
teaches studio art courses in computer
science on themes like interactive art
generative formed digital fabrication
information visualization and audio
visual performance at Carnegie Mellon
Golan is currently an associate
professor of electronic art with
courtesy appointments in computer
science and design in January he was
also appointed director of the studio
for creative inquiry of meta laboratory
within Carnegie Mellon dedicated to
supporting a typical interdisciplinary
and inner institutional research Golden
has spent half of his life as an artist
embedded within technological research
environments at places like MIT
laboratory ARS electronica future lab in
the interval Research Center in Palo
Alto goal
these guys wrote six long bars are
trying to see if I can talk that fast so
then that's good I worked hard at trying
to time this anyway our last panelist is
Jessica tribe us jessica is CEO and
founder of etc exit Ament a company
developing training software by applying
simulation and video game techniques for
more effective learning retention the
company was founded in 2005 by faculty
and graduates of Carnegie Mellon's
entertainment Technology Center which is
a global program successfully mixing
artisan technologists and working with
leading corporations foundations schools
and museums to build new tools for
inspiration entertainment and education
jessica also serves as director of exit
Ament at the et Cie and has contributed
to Carnegie Mellon's recognition as an
international leader in marrying
engaging interface with education and
learning at CMU Jessica's research
focuses on how to build game based
learning to engage in motivate with
emphasis on exploring younger
generations and at her company she
focuses on why it makes sense that is
how you make money for corporations to
employ this type of training to current
and incoming employees prior to working
with interactive technologies Jessica
spent several years in marketing
business development and project
management with Viacom and Alta Vista in
here in Palo Alto she has also worked as
an assistant with flower films drew
barrymore's production company and
jessica received her BA from cornell and
her master's in entertainment technology
from carnegie mellon
okay let's see how this goes so the
first question is I have for the all
four panels and we're just going to go
left to right is advances in technology
have always gone hand in hand with
advances in art and artistic expression
artists have often been the ones to
drive technologies in ways that
technologists hadn't imagined I'd like
to ask each of you to discuss how your
artistic expression has both leverage
and push technology and how it has
progressed over the course of your
careers and feel free to also comment on
any inspirations for what you have done
so we'll start with Ralph sure good
evening and thanks for coming the first
flip that you saw in the little wheel
that had spoke over was a one of about
10 or 15 films I made for the computer
science department at carnegie mellon
over a period of five or six years and
in each of those films i would try to
find an excuse to use a little bit of
computer animation to illustrate them
you also saw a very much younger version
of Raja Reddy in one of those films we
shot in 1978 and you know that field has
has grown and advanced tremendously
during that time and perhaps the
greatest success of achievement in that
field is what we accomplished in the
early days that pixar animation studios
and led by John Lasseter who was a
traditionally trained animator who was
fascinated with computer animation he
taught us very quickly on that really
the technology was not the guiding force
behind what made great films it was
really all about storytelling and about
character and the emotional impact that
had on an audience but what we also
learned is that the advances in the
technology were driving the artist to
think of new ideas and the artists
themselves were pushing the
technologists and and so we had a
tremendous relationship between our
computer scientists and our artists at
that company to constantly be the loyal
opposition to each other to egg each
other on to greater and greater things
that neither group had ever considered
doing before
and to pushing the limits of what
they've done and and that company still
today represents the very best practices
in that sort of arena and that's been
the case in a lot of the work that I've
done over the years as well because the
advances in visual picture making visual
storytelling have improved so much that
years ago when I used to go to the
siggraph annual convention which is an
ACM convention for graphics computer
graphics it was always amazing to see
just the simplest piece of animation in
the 1980s of maybe just a candle sitting
on a table and a curtain blowing next to
it would get a raving standing ovation
from the audience but if you go there in
more recent years you come to realize
that the the art form and the technology
has matured to the point where anything
we finally accomplished what we had
always hoped to do and that is that
anything is possible anything you can
imagine you can now visualize within
reason and you look at the special
effects and films that are coming out
you see what's available on television
but you also see what's available on the
desktop and these emerging technologies
in a way have a way of sort of
democratizing our ability to create or
everybody's ability to create things
when I was a grad student at CMU they
wheeled in the very first laser printer
which was the size of an
air-conditioning unit and today now sits
on everybody's desk and and because of
that it brought around a change in
desktop publishing that we all are very
familiar with similarly we now see
changes in the ability to create images
and I work with the director on this
pilot for Fox who carries around a
laptop that has final cut pro and pro
tools on it and he is his own one-man
sound editor picture editor and music
composer for the work he does and so the
technology in the arts keep driving each
other and they personalize each other in
very interesting ways as we move forward
great thank you Richard my turn um I got
the chance to work with Ralph for a
small window of time at Electronic Arts
and one of the things that I learned out
of that process of working with people
like wealthy are actually trained what
they do unlike me it is that there are
things we can have in common even if we
don't have a lot of training and that's
true love of our audience so in a little
video I showed you was those are my
people I love those people's a couple of
Mark are actually my kids too but anyway
there was a big guy with a Raiders
uniform here on the right-hand side with
silver big silver numbers on them loser
dude no now that would be funnier when I
when I started in the video game
business the sports part of the video
game business was about 1% and it was
you know less than 1% generally jocks
didn't play video games those are not
people that hung out together and so one
of the things that I had grown up was I
always kind of crossed all those
boundaries in school I got with
everybody in so I had my lettered in
chess and played on the baseball team
very unusual combination anyway the net
result of that was that I like those
people and I wanted them to like my
products so when I started making sports
video games that weren't about things
that were designed to make jocks feel
good about the fact that they could beat
up nerds buta beat up Jax but I wanted
to make jokes like it a big chunk of
that was to make it look like their
experience of television sports and so
what we did from the very beginning was
to make our video games look like TV
sports when we first tried to do that we
tried to use the text that they used and
it was these big ugly blocks and it
covered up everything so the net effect
was we we decided okay we're going to
shove it up in the corner because I
really got to know the down in the
distance I got to know at the time is so
we shoved it up in the corner about two
years in and about a half a dozen
stories about professional athletes
screaming itch I'm mad about the ratings
in the game I turned on the Fox
broadcast two years in and all of a
sudden up in the lower left upper
left-hand corner was a little tiny
scoreboard just like throwing I had
and over the next several years we
discovered that bit by bit piece by
piece we had redrawn what television
sports looked like it wasn't on purpose
but what we had done is rebuilt that
entire business so that's very
validating it's very gratifying and it
was a complete accident thank you Golan
hi um thanks I'm really chuffed to be
here and thanks ed and thanks everyone
for having me here and Carnegie Mellon's
my new home and I'm really delighted to
be there have been there teaching since
2004 and so I guess just for these
couple minutes I thought I'd talk about
sort of what I do and you could call me
a new media artist or a technology-based
artist as ed has I explore new forms of
art that are made possible by the kinds
of technologies that you're all
inventing and I feel that one of the
duties of an artist one is to explore
the medium of his or her day nowadays
without any disrespect to traditional
media we have a complete revolution in
how we can communicate and new ways of
reaching people and so a large part of
what I do is to explore what's
aesthetically possible so to do that I
make the one particular thing that I'm
interested in is making the invisible
visible and sort of allowing people to
learn something about themselves and so
sort of two threads of my work and I'll
show you some in just a moment is about
visualizing millions of communications
sort of visualizing mass communications
through techniques of information
visualization but with the objective not
necessarily of showing something
utilitarian but actually showing us
something interesting about ourselves
holding up a mirror if you will to
culture from let's say a weird angle and
allowing us to see ourselves from a way
that we've never seen each other before
and I also do a serve separate body of
work primarily concerned with
visualizing individual behavior allowing
people to learn something about
themselves that puts them in touch with
themselves through our kind of creative
flow state in a way where they learn
about their own potential as actors and
this work is heavily concerned with
interactivity or response itself as a
medium and so the work that I do is is
less about how it looks or how it sounds
then about the quality of response
that's that's elicited so with that I
thought I'd show a quick video roll it
we got so this project behind me is one
of these visualizations of mass
communications a friend of mine had all
of the blogs on a hard drive it wasn't
that big actually on a terabyte and so
we decided to say well what happens if
we search for all the instances have
broke up and dumped me and we end up
ended up with about 200,000 for 2006 all
the all the romantic breakups from that
year and and sort of learned like what
do they have in common and we discovered
that that as unique as you think your
pain is it's actually a lot of people
talk like you this is a project which is
another kind of visualization of
interactive behavior it's concerned with
visualizing speech and the fiction that
speech could cast visited shadows and in
this project we have two professional
vocalist with very extended sort of
vocal repertoire and we're serve
exploring different ways of visualizing
how they they speak shout bark and and
laugh and so forth and sing in this case
they're painting with their voices so
all for the projects you're seeing here
completed since i came to carnegie
mellon to graphical projects and the
next ones coming up are our robotic
since one major appeal for me to come to
carnegie mellon was the fantastic
robotics that's there this is a project
that's designed to answer the questions
where what if artwork was aware of the
fact that we were looking at it and what
if we could look back at us and and so
it's called opto-isolator that the beta
main goal of the project is to sort of
reduce the psychosocial phenomenon of
eye contact down to its absolute sort of
simplest athletes and this project you
saw at the very beginning from last
summer is a large robot on top of the
Pittsburgh Center for the Arts trying to
convey the sense that it's continually
surprised to see you
and in this way sort of communicate that
maybe there's something there's
something special in all of us that sort
of worth paying attention to so for this
was actually character animation real
time synthetic character animation for a
novel biological structure that had
never been done before I mean a new
biology finally this will fade to what
I'm doing now in addition to my art
practice I'm I've since January been
appointed to be the director of the
studio for creative inquiry this is a
special metal laboratory within Carnegie
Mellon at school college of arts ed
mentioned which is supporting artists
projects and trying to make interesting
things happen at the borderline between
art and engineering science and
technology so with that I'm a time thank
you very much
Jessica well my background is actually
in from the theater I I got my undergrad
degree in both theatre in English so I
was focused on performance acting
writing stories and something that I
found that really inspires me are great
stories and then once I see a great
story I want to be a character in it so
I guess that sort of goes back to my
performance background and you know
we've used technologies to serve the
goals of the story you can also define
story as problems that we're trying to
solve and I and I sort of make the
metaphor to sort of the problems that
we're trying to solve and and as the day
naman and writing that and being able to
write that so I look at problems such as
how can we get kids more engaged in
school in some of the things that
they're learning with obvious goal of
trying to make them better prepared for
the world I look at how can museums
really make some of the history come
alive and maybe with a result of
learning from that history or one thing
that I'm doing in our company that I'm
really passionate about how can we get
younger inexperienced workers to be as
passionate and interested in engaged in
in their training or in safety as the
30-year veterans obviously that's
important so that accidents can be
mitigated so you know I spend a lot of
time thinking about the experiences of
other people or other characters in in
this interactive story to solve problems
and another thing that's really inspired
me which it really made Carnegie Mellon
a great fit for me for my master's
degree was the interdisciplinary work
structure and this is something that we
talked about a lot when I went to get my
masters in her
and technology at the entertainment
Technology Center the fundamental
courses two of the fundamental courses
included reading Aristotle's Poetics and
taking improvisational acting and I
thought oh I'm right at home they want
me to tell stories and they want me to
participate in them and that that was
that was really really great considering
how intimidating it can be for someone
that functions mostly on the right side
of her brain to interact with
technologists and I'm constantly working
in interdisciplinary teams and it just
wouldn't have it any other way because
that's that's the way we solve the
problems that we're working on or create
the stories that we're telling great
thank you ok so we've heard a little bit
about the importance of stories audience
technology for animation and and
robotics and that's what would all of
these people all of the panels have been
doing so far I'd now like to get you to
think a little bit about the future and
given all that's changed since the 1990s
I'd like to eat you to ponder what you
think the next 10 years might be and to
predict some of the changes and how you
think they'll affect your own work and
for example if you were granted one wish
in terms of tools or technology what
would it be and how would you use it
will start with Ralph well it's hard to
predict the future because it was hard
to predict it even back when we started
working in some of these areas but for
bi work mainly in what you would still
call mainly linear media of conventional
movies and storytelling and television
and that sort of thing and be and given
that I work a lot in animation what is
most intriguing is any tool that
increases the immediacy of performance
the immediacy of storytelling in the
animation medium and what that boils
down to a lot is the ability to actually
animate instead of making a film in
three years but to be able to animate as
closely to real time as possible and
we've worked a little bit at alligator
planet with a couple of systems that
allowed us to do that but they've never
really been satisfactory at the same
time there's been a growing area the
called machinima which is actually tying
together what the video game industry is
doing in terms of creating real-time 3d
graphics 3d motion with the ability to
actually control it as most game players
already do through joysticks and other
devices and that to me is one of the
really interesting areas if we were an
engineering point of view I would say
it's a way to do rapid prototyping of
animated films and storytelling but it
goes way beyond that because one can
start to experiment with things in real
time that might otherwise take months
even years to produce so that's an error
the future that really intrigues me good
thinking Richard I know what I want I
want a fun o meter I want the ability to
record fun i'll let me explain why in
the time that I what you are probably
five or 10 when we started I'm older
than I think he is but anyway when we
started the amount of processing power
we had is infinitesimal by comparison
today literally in the time I've been in
the business we've had a 100,000 times
increase in processing power and do you
want to know how much we spent figuring
out if people are having fun just about
zero it seems to me fundamentally broken
that an interactive media doesn't know
who's playing the game that if they're
having any fun and so one of the ways
that we're going to expand and reach
audiences beyond the current audiences
that we have is to build products that
are paying attention to who's playing it
and whether or not it's what they want
to get out of it well we're kind of a
cusp of this there are small little
windows of insight the folks who made
lego star wars for those you who know
you play that game you will not beat the
death beat you to death it will help you
out and eventually open the door for you
and let you in we've got to do that more
often and suddenly these games become
much more appealing to a while to a
wider group great going Thanks well I
can't imagine that out here in Silicon
Valley you guys don't get enough
prognostication and it's a dangerous
business actually I quote that I like a
lot is that the future is already here
is just not evenly distributed
and when wet I mean I I see all kinds of
crazy things some guy on the on the
internet the other day a filmmaker who
was missing an eye from an accident he's
having a very very tiny camera custom
made and implanted in his eye socket and
he's going to be making fantastic um you
know documentaries but I actually don't
think that something like that is going
to be is I actually don't think that's
gonna be too uncommon in the future for
example but when I think so what I think
about like what I would like is the
dream the dream thing is less a specific
technology then some of the ways that
companies are working now with advanced
things that are coming out of their
laboratories which is to serve share it
and open-source way because suddenly a
lot more people can get involved as
early adopters or as makers as creators
in using these kinds of things when I
think about sort of the future in the
near term and possibly even the long
term especially as we look at oil
getting more expensive i see something
where there's a lot more local
production and i think that there's
gonna be several things that are really
going to help that I mean I look at
crowdsourcing I don't know if any of you
guys follow Tim O'Reilly to it but he
just talked yesterday about company
called local motors com where people are
crowdsourcing car design the motto of
this company is a what if we listened
and and and you know but the idea of
like crowdsourcing game design
crowdsourcing car design and ultimately
crowdsourcing large artworks which is
closer to my own field is I think
something is that's that's actually
going to get increasingly common where
suddenly collective intelligence is
harnessed instantaneously and rapidly to
serve zap certain problems or or
objectives and then to rapidly dissipate
I think that's particularly going to
happen as rapid prototyping moves
towards desktop just a moment ago you
know we heard about a laser printer that
was the first one there everyone's
excited to use this thing is the size of
this table that's happening now with 3d
printers and laser cutters and other
kinds of rapid prototyping machines and
that's really going to become something
you have on your desktop and that's
going to interact I think in a very
exciting way with maker culture etsy
culture and you know Maker Faire culture
where we have suddenly entirely new ways
of thinking about making things yourself
so anyway as we head towards an Internet
of Things as count as Kevin Kelly puts
it like lots of little things that are
suddenly on the internet and all
relating to each other I think we should
expect to see lots of people making
things on their own
great hey Jessica yeah as far as dream
tools i mean my dream to center around
travel and communication i mean travel
I'd like the time to time travel or have
a jet pack i would use those two things
just get around faster but as far as
communication i mean it seems well i'd
like to have some sort of a tool that
assimilates different different
languages so that you can interact with
different cultures and different places
a little bit better i'm not really sure
what that means but somewhere in my head
that makes sense um but as far as the
future i mean to Colin's point about
crowdsourcing it's absolutely clear to
me anyway that people will continue to
drive their entertainment and education
experiences and really be the the
participant in what that means um you
know there's just so much data sharing
and sourcing going on right now and
that's just going to continue I think to
be generated in such a way where you
know so much of our realities is going
to actually be augmented you know so
much it was going to be digital where we
can share and communicate and create our
own stories together and over time it
doesn't have to be real time it could be
well real time but the spread spread out
over time so I just think that there's
so much cool stuff happening right now
that will continue to put people in
charge of the experiences and in driving
them right thank you okay now what I'd
like to do is I have questions directed
for each of the panelists and hopefully
relevant to really what each of them has
been doing so again just because he's
right next to me i'll start with Ralph
so Ralph the animation is more and more
becoming a presence in vehicles and
entertainment at adults and adults and
not just children your projects for
adult swim or examples of that what do
you think is happening now and do you
think we will see more of this animation
on more complex than adult oriented
themes and
do you see that business developing her
we live in a I'll start with one thing
with Jessica and I were talking at the
just before this tonight and she was
explaining how at cetera they're
creating training programs for people
who don't read the manuals anymore and
for people who find our stood correctly
who really need visual guidance and how
to be trained we took the job and her
two particular project and we live in a
sort of post literate world in many
respects I mean there's you know we all
do a tremendous amount more reading on
the web then we might have done
otherwise and at the same time its aided
and abetted by a lot of visual tools and
animation is now going through what many
call it's sort of second Golden Age the
first Golden Age being the early years
of Disney and now the second Golden Age
is basically because a generation has
grown up with animation and visual
storytelling and takes it for granted
the emergence of graphic novels the
emergence of a variety of other
storytelling techniques that depend so
heavily on visuals is in existence
because an older generation expects and
and requires that as part of the way in
which they're attained and the beauty of
animation is that allows us to tell
stories that we can't quite tell with
live-action characters and we can't
quite tell in a very realistic manner we
need a bit of fantasy a little
fantastical air to them and that is why
we see a lot more animation on
television a lot more animation in
theaters there's an audience of adults
now who appreciate that sure rich could
answer the question of why more adults
are playing video games as well that
hold there's a whole generation I grew
up with it they expect it as part of the
entertainment spectrum that they want to
be engaged in and they take it for
granted that they want to have it there
the emergence of The Simpsons king of
the hill south park even our low project
lucy the daughter of the devil which was
a great deal of fun to work on our
examples of adult oriented storytelling
that works best in animation and that
works for the
the population that exists right now
that relies on it so they've grown up
with it and they come to expect it so it
sounds like we will be seeing a lot more
adult absolutely right so Richard
despite lots of talk about diversity of
gaming it seems to me that games like
madden football are still pretty much
oriented towards a competitive young
adolescent males and I'm wondering if
you think that this trend will continue
or do you see that there are
opportunities for titles and for making
money that have a broader appeal do and
also at the same time do you imagine
given some of the tools we've been
talking about being able to build games
targeted very specific demographics and
really trying and I'm wondering how you
see that affecting your business going
forward sure so I've got a couple things
to talk about there but I didn't realize
until this moment that I'm helping
create your whole business I've spent 25
years destroying the attention span of
every person
so I'm going to move on to some new
people of course we've had a couple kind
of remarkable things happen Electronic
Arts in the last and last month and I
won't take any personal credit really
any of it both but we've had two number
ones this month at the same time for the
first time in a long time for rihanna's
that's been really gratifying for yeah
we had the number one product on the pc
chart and then um one product on the wii
chart at the same time but i want to
talk about another product that's a kind
of an internal number one first we run
an online system called Pogo anybody
here ever used that oh brother that
didn't work well apparently we have the
wrong bank robber you know we don't have
the ride and rafa so it turns out that
pogo is a service for about 1.4 million
subscribers in the US and roughly 10
times that many users on a daily basis
the average customers a 34 year old
woman she plays for nine hours a week
which by the way is only two hours a
week less than my hardcore video console
players play if you ask her she's not a
game at the same time this this month we
put a product on the top of the we chart
and the very first time Electronic Arts
has ever actually had a number one chart
Neville a product on a Nintendo chart
and it's a product built for 25 to 30
year old women finally really Sims
through this month on the pc chart it's
been praying Lee about twenty-five
percent of the pc business for a long
time and the average customer for that
product is a girl between the ages of 17
and 22 so in other words the three most
important economic engines of EA's
growth this quarter are all made for
girls so I guess our business is
changing a little hot and very
impressive golden when I think of your
work it is demonstrative of what happens
when there's oh really done
sorry sorry okay we'll try that again I
didn't cut you often I were you were
finished Richard and I thank you because
always bad when you cut off your
panelists anyway golden what I think of
your work it's demonstrative of what
happens when there's a productive
relationship between artists and
technologists I'm wondering if you could
comment on how your art research has led
to some new technologies and how
important questions in computer science
how important questions in computer
science will find their answers in some
of the kind of art that you go do yeah
thanks um I actually think it was
president Cohen who said something that
struck me maybe a few months ago he said
engineers solve problems and artists
make new ones and this was this was
something that that really kind of stuck
with me because I don't necessarily know
if the artists will necessarily solve
the problems although one thing that
we're starting to see is a new breed of
artists technologists researchers who
can also solve the problems but I think
there's been a lot of really interesting
examples of artists who work in the
context of research laboratories who
helped propel technologies forward I've
seen this at all the sort of really
well-known significant laboratories have
been built that have invented the stuff
that we use today Xerox PARC Apple atg
you know Atari Cambridge research labs
interval rise to work and you know
artists participating in production of
patents I have I have myself so I also
think of examples like early media art
and and some examples like for example
Myron Krugers video place from 1974
which was really in many ways set the
whole template for what we now see is
the sony I toy but he was not only one
of the first artists to use a camera in
interactive art but really one of the
first computer artists at all so if you
run a research lab get an artist it's a
good it's a good it's a good investment
I think and you guys have said this
before that the technology and culture
exists in a really important feedback
and we're more aware of that than ever
that tech makes new forms of
communication possible and communication
prompts new forms of technological
development Peter Lee who's the head of
the compute
department at Carnegie Mellon is has
sort of articulated this really well by
saying that that a lot of the new
problems in computer science are not of
the John von Neumann era but are really
of the sort of the consequence of
communications technologies hitting us
and we have suddenly a huge need for
technologies that understand how we
communicate why we communicate and
what's worth communicating and artists
have a main line on that I want to end
just really quickly with sort of saying
like how we are addressing at at
Carnegie Mellon because one thing that
that the Carnegie Mellon has done
historically really well is arts and
technologies but the combination of the
tomb has really been motivated i think
since the since the revolution in
communications technologies and just
since basically one year ago we have a
new Bachelors of computer science and
art it's a hybrid program which is
unique in the nation and it's it's just
one way of thinking about about a way
that that a student can get a sort of
integrated double degree in connecting
these areas and allowing these kinds of
synapses to fire that that haven't been
able to happen before so that's sort of
an indicator of progress and something
to look forward to from the the future
artists technologists researchers who
really will be both making the problems
and solving them as themselves right in
front of Jessica as we just heard there
may be some risk that video games erode
people's attention though actually if
you'd spend nine hours doing something I
think you're being pretty good attention
to it but the so so maybe my question
isn't really a good one but but to the
extent that there is this issue about
attention span and really it's not as
video games with its computers in
general and all the time we spend going
back and forth i'm wondering in in your
business and as you're trying to use
games to teach people how you are
reacting and dealing with people who
really are concerned that video games
and this form of teaching may not be
best for for students well most of the
resistance i get is just generally when
people don't know that much about video
games or have never played video games
you know I I personally think they're
going to save the world so
so on the other side of the spectrum but
there's no doubt that video games can be
very very powerful for communication and
you know get back to the story it
depends what what story like what movie
you want your kid to watch you know but
but the very powerful for communication
I mean most of the people probably in
this room realize that there's a lot of
problem solving going on in a lot of
these games there's communication and
collaboration and a lot of instances
there's explore exploring discovery
adventure role-playing certainly trial
by error and then of course you know
you're back to the role playing the one
thing that the games really allow us to
do is to interact to have that agency
and be able to participate to drive the
story and interestingly enough all of
this stuff in games maps really really
well to proven principles for how we
learn it's something if we're motivated
to do something if we can create
something that motivates someone you're
not going to be able to stop them from
learning what they need to learn do you
know what I mean and so there are see if
you design something with it's
motivating that has clear goals and
clear rewards clear feedback all of this
stuff is built into you know just like
simulation just like flight simulation
no one would argue for the last 30 or 40
years why people learn better that way
and so we're just translating that to
the using games so that people can can
learn and discover and share in a more
effective way that's great so it sounds
like your company will have lots of
great tools for people to learn gains
for people to learn with so we have a
little bit of time left and so I'd like
to if there are some questions what I'd
like you to do is there's a microphone I
think on either side so as you go up to
the mic Jamie's near one so question
over here hi my name is Calvin chavarria
I'm a pepper red and nine
9 just question for the panel I guess
first of all I think you guys should
talk to President Obama who encourages
parents not to let kids play video games
and read some books that is a debate in
our house so I get some some emulations
today the question relates to copy years
ago the phenomenon was the second life
and it's sort of tapered off with the
financial crisis and you know the
valuations that companies were getting
what do you think Second Life where is
going in terms of the societal
phenomenon and you know what its impacts
going to be and what is what is this
purpose in terms of real life thanks
great thanks to a question so we want to
take that on you know I think second
life is just another incarnation of a
phenomenon we've seen in our business
for a long time which is people like
being people who aren't themselves and
what we've been in the business of the
of cattle filling those fantasies over
the years who in here has played
rockband her guitar hero we're doing
better now thank you you talked to Alex
who's creative that product he
languished for about the better part of
a decade and a half tried to make music
games and he wasn't successful until he
figured out that a picture of Jimi
Hendrix with a Stratocaster is cool and
that that's actually what people wanted
to be they don't want to learn how to
play music they just wanted to be Jimmy
and so I guess at the bottom of this we
all want to be other people we all want
to have other experiences I think that's
pretty much with Jessica was saying
earlier the other thing I'd say in
reference to the White House
circumstance is there are three things
that I thought would never be in the
White House that are there now a pack of
newport cigarettes on earth wind and
fire album and a nintendo wii from my
perspective he could say all he likes
but he's already spoke with his body
hey Jessica do you want to respond to
the questioner oh I agree with maturity
the one thing that I wanted to touch on
that was part of the question was sort
of at least how I'm taking it i lookin
on one side of my head how companies are
going to pay for this why are they going
to pay what is this distill down to why
is this going to be a half to have for
them and we've been able to sort of
crack that not a little bit and it
suddenly no one take this the wrong way
but you know I've go into a lot of
executives that are 60 year old men that
don't play video games necessarily and
it's like oh here comes here comes video
game girl and and it you know so I have
to convince them at the end of the day
you know that and it suddenly becomes
okay this isn't about video games and
Wow because yeah with 18 to 30 year olds
coming into the workforce that the least
experienced yeah I get that but that's
not it's not because of a while video
games and the kids love video games it
has nothing to do with that it has to do
with we need these people to have
retained this information because
there's a huge cost associated with that
and in my case we're trying to save
lives so great another question okay oh
hi I'm Michael Michael Sharon um are you
know of course get to state your school
your year you know yeah started in
physics graduated and drama
question I have is with the huge number
of people that are sort of discovering
and using Twitter where you're limited
by a hundred and forty text characters
and they're having these huge
interactive experiences where you can
broadcast too many and interact with
many but you're limited by 140
characters of text what do you think
would be the next generation of to
device that would allow much richer
communication and interaction and what
platform would it be on what would it
look like I'm thinking this is one of
those things golden knows the answer to
I've been thinking a lot about Twitter
this week obviously because of the Iran
elections I'm not sure people
necessarily want a rich or Twitter but I
do think that that Twitter is one part
of a big ecology there's a fantastic
professor the michael wesch in in the
south somewhere Kansas I think whose
calls himself a digital anthropologist
digital ethnography a digital
ethnographer and he's really interesting
to read because he's providing really
interesting insight on how people use
these tools and why and I think the
constraint to Twitter is actually one of
the things that makes it makes it
successful the fact that it is just 140
characters it's you don't necessarily
have to think that I need a full-fledged
virtual reality to have necessarily a
more effective or more rich
communication people are using it
interesting ways but i think that the
Second Life is is one one kind of
platform and if you suddenly had second
life on your phone and a mobile device
and then whatever that means then you've
you've got maybe what you're talking
about i don't see that people wouldn't
want it i actually respectfully disagree
with richard i think that if you look at
how people are using youtube for example
you find that that other than sort of
all the random you know you know kittens
riding a skateboard kind of thing you
find you find many people who are
putting on costumes and putting on
personalities and acting in ways of
fantasy where they sort of say like i'm
going to be this personality today but
you also find a lot of people who want
to be themselves and want to use YouTube
as a way of discovering and explaining
who they are sometimes just to
themselves and sometimes to the world so
if we think about about what Second Life
where that becomes the objective not
necessarily being Jimi Hendrix but maybe
just being yourself that sounds like the
kind of virtual reality that the Second
Life is also supporting now maybe it's
not the most convenient format to be
having to be in a dark room you know at
your desktop so when the mobile platform
becomes something that's really high
bandwidth we could look forward to that
but I don't think it's going to replace
text the the question is more about like
with Twitter not not a problem of
richness but a problem let's say of
validation and identity like how do we
know who you are what you say you are
and is it fact and things like that
thank you everyone have one last
question ok remember state your name and
your affiliation my name is lisa ann
Pinkerton and uh school of drama
ninety-nine Hein school 2004 Carnegie
Mellon I had a great opportunity to
teach theatre to a group of homeschool
kids and it helps to socialize them and
that sort of thing and what I learned
from those homeschool kids was that they
were learning certain topics because
they were interested in them and they
would spend a whole month learning about
dinosaurs and all the history of the
dinosaurs the science blah blah and
those children knew absolutely
everything there was to know and what I
realized was that these kids are
learning in a way that sort of seems
like we're genetically predisposed to
learn which is to learn what we're most
interested in and I'm wondering I I'm
wondering what your thoughts are on how
art and technology and video games are
bringing us sort of back to that and out
of the very controlled schoolroom
setting that we may not be genetically
predisposed to learn in some wondering
what your thoughts are good go for it
mean you know I it goes back to the way
I answered the last question about
trying to understand what works in
simulation flight simulation for pilot
training and and what works you know
talking to behavioral psychologists in
trying to understand how we learn you
know how do you make that cognitive
transfer in the same way is if you're
really hands-on doing it because no
one's going to debate it if you just you
get thrown into the situation that's how
you learn the best and there's there's
incentives and you know that
everything's like a game here's your job
given this much time and all these other
variables so come there's a lot of talk
it the Carnegie Mellon the entertainment
Technology Center and across campus of
how do we translate this into the
classrooms because the this that the
kids are going home and do Twitter or
video games or and this has been going
on for 15 20 years you know and one
minute to that sure I think that what's
interesting to think about that is
people are aghast that somebody spent a
month learning about dinosaurs just
nothing but dinosaurs but the facts are
that's not what happened they didn't
learn about dinosaurs they learned about
biology and they learned about geology
and they learned about plate tectonics
and they learned about how the dinosaurs
got formed if they like they were lucky
they learned what calcium was it's a
byproduct I think what we found out
about video games is people learn things
you would not believe and often that you
don't intend spore is a product we built
for one audience and got discovered by
another we built it for adults thinking
it would be this great broad sweeping
epic for grownups and it turns out that
it is the obsession of eight to
ten-year-old boys and they treat it as
their own private little laboratory chur
laboratory and the net result is they
understand evolutionary forces because
they have iterated it and had ended in a
hands-on way that's virtually impossible
any other way was that our intention
maybe we'll thought about it once but I
guarantee it wasn't the center of what
we were trying to do your audience is
always surprising
ten seconds to your point I think it's
about relevancy or these things are all
interrelated but you kind of think about
how you learned some history yeah 1789
this happened on this day it's sort of
in a bullet point format I how to
memorize that as opposed to hear were
the steaks and you know here's the story
and the stakes were high and and
throwing you into that situation to
really bring meaning to that and games
allow us to do that if designed in the
right way it's just gluten we've got to
figure out how not to make them hear
more of experience not huge budgets and
long long cycles and and to have people
contribute to them sorry well I I just
like that it won one quick thing because
I'm I'm in the trenches right now with
with you typically freshman
undergraduates first year students and a
lot of them really think software is
made by someone else you guys and it's
it's really important in terms of what
we're trying to do at Carnegie Mellon is
to make them aware that it's actually
something that they can make themselves
and there's such a huge revolution in
allowing people to make software of
their own these days it's totally
transformed especially for artists and
designers but really for anyone it's
been it's so much easier than when you
guys were in school it's it's it's it's
profoundly easier now and allowing them
to serve experience that get awake in
the to how they can suddenly makes offer
for the first time for themselves and
suddenly they can make software that
answers a problem that they have gets to
that kind of engagement that I think
you're seeing with the homeschool
students
you